[Music]
it has already been mentioned that each
of the opposites in which the ethical
substance exists contains the entire
substance and all the moments of its
content is that the community is that
substance conscious of what it actually
does the other side has the form of
immediate substance or substance that
simply is the latter is thus on the one
hand the inner notion or general
possibility of the ethical sphere in
general but on the other hand equally
contains within at the moment of self
consciousness this moment which
expresses the ethical sphere in this
element of immediacy or simple being or
which is an immediate consciousness of
itself both as essence and is this
particular self in another ie as a
natural ethical community this is the
family the family is the unconscious
still an inner notion of the ethical
order stands opposed to its actual self
conscious existence and the elements of
the nation's actual existence it stands
opposed to the nation itself as the
immediate being of the ethical order it
stands over against that order which
sheets and maintains itself by working
for the universal the panada takes stand
opposed to the universal spirit
we come now to paragraph 450 where Hegel
is going to make the divine law much
more concrete both in what it is ie as
the family and in terms of what it is
opposed to and how it is opposed to it
that is the community or the human law
Hegel begins this this paragraph by
stressing a point that he's going to
reemphasize at several places throughout
this paragraph namely that when we're
talking about the ethical substance or
we're talking about spirit however we
want to frame it it's splitting into two
moments does not mean that each of the
moments is you know losing part of
itself and holding on to another part of
itself rather as he says both of these
moments do in fact continue on embodying
the totality or the whole of the ethical
substance he says each of the opposites
the the opposed set it said against each
other things in which the ethical
substance exists each contains the
entire substance so both are the ethical
substance and in a certain respect to
attempt to isolate and have the ethical
substance without one side would be to
lose the ethical substance in a certain
way there's more that could be said
about that but I just want to pass over
that sort of a pregnant remark something
worth mulling over now he goes on and he
also says both sides not only contain
the entire ethical substance they
contain all the moments of its content
so this doesn't mean that they're
identical but this means that they do
both have what is really primary what is
really essential in each of the sides
one of those things that I put up here
on the board because I want to distress
this both contain self-consciousness
they do not contain it however in the
same way and here is where the interplay
begins so he says if the community is
that substance conscious of what it
actually does why is the community the
substance conscious of what it actually
does because it has laws human laws
which are promulgated or at least you
know are there available as vitta as
customs or ethical norms and people can
you know see this stuff somewhere they
may not see it written now necessarily
but they can at least talk about it
there is a government people understand
where things fit in if things are above
the board as we said their manifest so
he says the other side is the form of
immediate substance or substance that
simply is so it sounds here like we're
talking about the for itself and the in
itself and to a certain sense that
that's true except this is a in itself
that is going to become progressively
for itself and this by being for itself
is already sort of in itself the law has
become something that you know are just
just there in a pure positivity as we
see later on so he goes on he says the
latter what is that the family right
the latter is on the one hand the inner
notion or general possibility of the
ethical sphere in general but on the
other hand equally contains within at
the moment of self consciousness not
self-consciousness as yet explicitly
conscious of self but self-consciousness
in a more subterranean unconscious
manner as we're going to see now he goes
on and he says here we go the general
possibility the ethical sphere in
general right there is something that
goes on within this side that isn't
being adequately dealt with on on this
side so he says the moment which
expresses the ethical sphere and this
element of immediacy or simple being or
which is an immediate conscious
of itself both as essence and is this
particular self in another that is as a
natural ethical community this is he
says the family now you know we don't
want to say well you know but what about
you know step stepchildren and and you
know divorces and all know Hegel is
talking about the family in the
traditional sense understood as a basic
unit of the society but also as a
peering off of male and female
reproduction within there probably
extension back to previous generations
the sort of thing that we're talking
about in in traditional societies when
we talk about the breakdown of the
family we have that sort of thing in
mind right and so what are they telling
us about the family the family as the
unconscious still inner notion of the
ethical order stands opposed to its
actual self conscious existence
what is this actual self conscious
existence the family is part of the
community the family as belonging to
perhaps a larger family you know the
clan which then he has you know people
in charge or the family as belonging to
a particular residential area within a
Greek city-state or the family as we can
go on and on and on with all sorts of
interesting permutations but insofar as
its understanding at first where it fit
it's getting that idea essentially from
the society which is telling it okay you
are a household you are a family you
count in this way and not in this way
here are the things you can do here's
the things that you can't do now within
that of course within that scope there's
this whole subterranean you know place
where the people who actually belong in
the family are living out there
relations with each other and unless the
state or the larger society becomes
somehow involved
they have no clue what the hell's going
on in here that could be good and that
can be bad right Hegel again is just
looking at this in sort of a generality
so he says as the elements of the
nation's actual existence it stands
opposed to the nation itself as the
immediate being of the ethical order it
stands over against that order which
shapes and maintains itself by working
for the universal that is the state
right or the nation the community the
penalties the the deities of the
household the ones to whom you would
make your your own private devotions
because they don't apply to everybody
else they just apply to you and those
who are related to you those Hegel says
stand opposed to the universal spirit so
we have an interesting disjuncture here
and the fundamental question that we're
going to ask ourself as we move forward
through this is does rationality does
the development of spirit and all the
things that go with it that Hegel is so
in favor of do they primarily fall on
the side of the state or does this
domain of the family in some respect
matter does it need to have its side
taken up and spoken for and the answer
is it is the second but now we have to
see how that plays out
however although the family is
immediately determined as an ethical
being it is within itself an ethical
entity only so far as it is not the
natural relationship of its members or
so far as their connection is an
immediate connection of separate actual
individuals for the ethical principle is
intrinsically universal and this natural
relationship is just as much a spiritual
one and it is only as a spiritual entity
that it is ethical we have to see what
constitutes its peculiar ethical
character in the first place because the
ethical principle is intrinsically
universal the ethical connection between
the members of the family is not that a
feeling or the relationship of love it
seems that that the ethical principle
must be placed in the relation of the
individual member of the family to the
whole family of the substance so that
the end and content of what he does and
actually is is solely the family but the
conscience and motivating the action of
this whole so far as it is directed
towards that whole is itself the
individual the acquisition and
maintenance of power and wealth is in
part concerned only with needs and
belongs to the sphere of appetite in
part they become in their higher
determination something that is only
mediated this determination does not
fall within the family itself but bears
on what is truly universal the community
it has rather a negative relation to the
family and consists in expelling the
individual from the family subduing the
natural aspect of separateness of his
existence and training him to be
virtuous to a life in and for the
universal the positive end peculiar to
the family as the individual as such now
in order that this relation should be
ethical neither he who performs the
action nor he to whom the action refers
can be in an accidental relationship as
happens perhaps in rendering some
assistance or service in a particular
case the content of the ethical action
must be substantial or whole and
universal therefore it can only be
related to the whole individual or to
the individual qua
individual and this again must know
be understood as if it were only
imagined that doing in a service would
promote its total happiness whereas the
service being an immediate and actual
deed produces only a particular effect
on him nor must we imagine that service
in the form of education that is in a
series of efforts really hands him in
his entirety for object and produces him
as a work for apart from the purpose
which is negatively connected with the
family the actual deed has only a
limited content finally just as little
should we understand the service as a
help in time of need by which in truth
the individual that is entirety is
rescued for such help it is itself a
completely contingent act the occasion
of which is an ordinary reality which
can either be or not be the deed then
which embraces the entire existence of
the blood relation does not concern the
citizen for he does not belong to the
family nor the individual who is to
become a citizen and will cease to count
as this particular individual it has as
its object and concept this particular
individual who belongs to the family but
is taken as a universal being freed from
it sensuous that is individual reality
the deed no longer concerns the living
but the dead the individual who after a
long succession of separate disconnected
experiences concentrates himself into a
single completed shape and has raised
himself out of the unrest of the
accidents of life into the calm of
simple universality but because it is
only as a citizen that he has actual and
substantial the individual so far as he
is not a citizen belongs to the family
is only an unreal impotent shadow
Hegel gets a good ways into paragraph
451 before he finally frames the
fundamental question that that this
entire paragraph is is working with and
answering in a lot of negative ways
before finally telling us what the
answer is and that question is what does
the family's ethical character is it
leak-tight consists in he asked this
only a little bit you know later after
raising one issue he says we have to see
what constitutes its peculiar ethical
character so what makes the family fit
leak in the sense of having to do with
the ethical substance or as we've talked
about it in the previous paragraphs is
in some way expressing one one
fundamental moment of the ethical
substance why the family well this leads
into a number of not quite negations but
certainly saying well you're not on the
right point that that actually does
happen but that's not what we're
focusing on here this is what we could
imagine Hegel to be saying to an
interlocutor and so there's a lot of
neither this nor this nor this nor this
not this going on in this paragraph and
I summarized them here so let's just run
through these fairly quickly and then
we'll come back to each of these in turn
family is not just about natural
relations it is not just about power
wealth or acquisition and maintenance
it's not just training for citizenship
or for virtue it's not just something
that's particularly
in its action it's not just about
education or raising like children for
example or dealing and it's not just
about providing help in need instead
there's something more fundamental Hagel
thinks that is going on here now that's
not to assert that this is actually
happening in all families there are good
families and there are bad families and
in a certain respect bad families
from this Hegelian perspective at least
insofar as what you know we're talking
about something here are not really
families in in this fundamental respect
that we're going to talk about this is a
very interesting point which we could
explore in much greater detail and which
which one could certainly think about in
terms of family dynamics and paradigms
but let's just go forward from what he's
got here so if there's a longish
paragraph so he says the family is
immediately determined as an ethical
being right so there is this immediate
determination as a place where we might
say ethics happens now what what the
hell does that mean ethics happens that
means that you know concerns about wrong
and right and good or bad and valuation
and choices get made a wonderful phrase
coming I think from Alistair McIntyre
who I think took it from somebody else I
think one of the depth psychologists
said that the family is the first school
of desire it is where it's the place
where we learn what has value and what
doesn't have value you know a great
example of this before we go into the
actual text which by the way and a
certain self-referential e applies to
the text is a valuation of reading if
you want a child to read so this is
something that the social scientists
have discovered and it may be you know
completely valid or only partly valid
don't worry about that think about it as
an illustration of this working here if
you want a child to read what is the
best thing that you can actually do is
it read to the child is it buy them lots
of books no it's actually for them to
see their parents reading not just
reading to them like a chore or is
something else but the parents reading
as something that they want to do
because the child then learns oh this is
something that adults think is worth
doing it's not just something that
they're doing to me because I'm not
smart enough to read it myself
or because they want to humor me or
because they feel like they ought to
it's something that is genuinely
valuable this is how hires are shaped
this is how people get their sense of
right and wrong and good or bad and
better and worse which is almost more
important than just you know sheer good
and bad right so the family is a place
where we might say ethics happens Hegel
called this being immediately determined
as an ethical being he says it is within
itself an ethical entity only so far as
it is not the natural relationship of
its members or so far as their
connection is an immediate connection of
separate actual individuals why for the
ethical principle is intrinsically
universal it goes beyond mere
particularity right and this natural
relationship is just as much a spiritual
one and it is only as a spiritual entity
that it is ethical so when we reduce the
relationship within the family to
something that is merely natural we are
taking away what Hegel calls its
spiritual dimension and this is not
about religion or spirituality and the
you know sort of sense that people I'm
spiritual but not religious mean he's
talking about something a higher level
of value than the merely natural one
that does not reduce to the needs of the
state or the marketplace or whatever
else it is that we want the family
provides us so long as we actually have
a functioning one with a locus where
higher values and higher Goods have the
possibility of being realized have the
possibility of being set out as
attractors have the possibility of being
worked on together so long as it's
conceived of as merely natural you know
men and women like to get together
because they have an innate you know
desire just like all the other animals
look at the dogs look at the cockroaches
they all got a mate and we just happen
to meet for a long time perhaps we do a
serial monogamy or perhaps you know you
know men
are by nature driven to to infidelity or
you know it's not an infidelity in a
natural setting is it because there's no
rules right and women want to hold on so
this is all the stuff the evolutionary
biologists and the people who do the
second sort of second-order theorizing
from evolutionary biology love to talk
about Hegel would say that's all nice
that's not what a family is really about
that that's not false although you know
the stuff about you know monogamy and
stuff that's pretty a lot of Thedas on
pretty sketchy basis you know to
generalize as a whole about male and
female relationship tough to do worth
spending some time with you know looking
at anthropological studies to do that
Hegel would say that's all besides the
point the family and even by extension
marriage or kinship or however you want
to think about it is not a purely
natural relationship as opposed to the
artificial relationship or the
distinctively human relationship of the
state the family is where something else
something important is going on so a
little bit later he's going to talk in
terms of here we go he comes back to
this not merely a natural relationship
he says the ethical connection between
the members of the family is not that of
feeling or the relationship of love now
you might think oh it sounds terrible
Hegel you know so we have a family and
there's no love within the family what
the hell kind of family are you talking
about I don't want to live in a family
like that Hegel was not saying that
there isn't love in the family he's
saying that the feeling of love is not
all there is to what's going on
that the ethical character of the family
is not just in the fact that we love
each other that we feel affection
towards each other that's nice that's
good
don't get rid of it
matter of fact would be a bad family if
it was lacking that but that's not we're
the ethical character of the family lies
in now notice he's talking about the
feeling of love here if you remember
back just you know a few sections before
when we're talking about you know the
commandment to love thy neighbor Hegel
says it's not just a feeling that's
being commanded it's an action that is
actually what's going to be happening in
the ethical character of the family
although he's not going to use the word
love there but there is something going
on that we could describe love as
comportment or action as opposed to
feeling the feeling can be just natural
right so he goes on and he says it seems
the ethical principle must be placed in
the relation of the individual member of
the family to the whole family of the
substance so that the end in content of
what he does and actually is is solely
the family okay so maybe that's the
point right so you as an individual
you're there to make your family proud
or you're there to build up your family
or you have this loyalty kin first screw
everybody else or you know kin first and
then everybody else after then Hegel
says no no that's not that's not it
either
why not he says the conscious end
motivating the action of this whole
insofar as it's directed towards that
this whole is itself the individual here
we're getting at something really
interested people who are obsessed with
the status or good name of their family
they're not really about ethics Hegel
say because what they're concerned with
is the family but - its members if
you're concerned about the family that
means that if you take the family as the
end that means that the other individual
fools in the family they are the
components they are the constituents of
that family that means that you take
them as the end so if you really value
your family that means that you value
all of the members you don't just value
the family as such there may be points
where you actually have to amputate a
limb you know somebody is really messing
up the family and you say well you know
we tried everything we possibly could
and then we tried some more and that
person is still really screwing things
up we're going to have to ostracize them
or kick them out or cut them off but for
the most part you're not going to be
doing that the notion of something like
for example honor killings would be
totally foreign to what Hegel is talking
about here that would be a cathodic 'el
understanding of the family from a
Hegelian perspective so he goes on and
he says the acquisition and maintenance
of power and wealth this is another
possibility maybe what the family is
really about is providing resources you
know acquisition and maintenance of
power and wealth now that is an
important function of families as a
matter of fact well-functioning families
will indeed if not acquire more wealth
will at least retain the wealth that
they have will provide for you know the
necessities of life and then something
beyond that so that the people within it
can flourish and grow but that's not the
whole point of the family that's not
where it's ethical status lies this is a
mistake many people make too isn't it
power wealth prestige connections being
a legacy at a particular school lining
yourself up for this or that those are
things that people do get obsessed about
and they do get obsessed about it in the
way that lends a kind of seriousness
that belongs to ethics to those pursuits
but that is not the ethical why not
Hegel zuzana T says
the acquisition of power and wealth is
in part concerned only with needs and
belongs to the sphere of appetite so
that's something natural right and in
other part they become in their higher
determination something that is only
mediated what is what does that mean he
goes on to tell us this determination
does not fall within the family itself
it bears on what's truly universal the
community it has rather a negative
relation to the family and consistent
expelling the individual from the
families for doing the natural at okay
we're going to go on into something else
there this whole business about
acquisition of power and wealth that's
how you play out your family these are
the other families or institutions or
other individuals within the realm of
the community it's not about the family
itself as a matter of fact if we wanted
to try to extend this we might say that
you know what could count as maintaining
wealth would not be maintaining
something in a bank account but holding
on to a parcel of land that everybody
has gotten to know we're holding on to
certain family heirlooms and passing
them down and not just passing them down
mutely or like museum pieces but passing
them down as something that everybody
has title to and everybody hears the
stories about again we could go much
further into detail on that this is an
extremely rich section here meditating
about the nature of the family ethical
status now I cut us off a little bit
we're leading into the next discussion I
put not just training for citizenship
Hagel here is going to talk about virtue
right he goes on and he says here we go
it's not just expelling the individuals
from the family subduing the natural
aspect and separateness of his existence
and training him to be virtuous to a
life in and for the universal no it's
not about the family producing good
citizens or good soldiers or good
consumers or good whatever the hell you
want because that's not treating the
individual within the family as
individual as having weight and value
and individual like Hegel says the
positive end peculiar to the family is
the individual as such the Niko's auntie
says in order that this relationship be
ethical neither he who performs the
action no nor he to whom the action
refers can be in an accidental
relationship as happens perhaps in
rendering some assistance or service in
a particular case it must be substantial
or whole and universal this is very
important it is related to the
individual as a whole individual or to
the individual qua universal this is
what I was talking about a little bit
earlier in terms of a different kind of
love not the love of feeling not the
love of just natural affection not the
love of desire right not even just the
love of we like to do the same thing
like eat the same foods and watch the
same TV shows or you know play ball on
the weekend this is love for who the
person fundamentally is even in how
they're screwed up even in how they're
not yet developed I mean think about
this appearance and children right I
mean parents anybody who's got a kid
your kid is not exactly up to par if you
think that they is you think that
they're perfect in every way that's
because you've deluded yourself but
you're totally blind to their many
imperfections and you love them anyway
right because you want what is good for
them and not just good for them as
little reflections of yourself or as how
you mediate your relationship to the
outside world or how you make yourself
look good with the neighbors or their
teachers or this and that but in
relation to that in relation to who they
are
and hopefully you know once they get
past their natural egoism and
selfishness that often extends well into
their 20s they have something like that
in relation to you as parents as well as
part of the family
they overlook all the crazy stupid
things that you did said forgot to do
you know your flaws and they appreciate
you as a whole person not just as
something that's instrumental for
something else not just something
contingent oh you know you happen to be
my dad you happen to be my kid you
happen to be my brother you happen to be
my cousin since you're here you know in
a way April Hagel would not be all that
amenable to that you know phrase from
the Fleetwood Mac song that so many
people love to quote especially when
they want to commit infidelity which is
if you can't be with the one you love
love the one you're with right now in a
certain sense you are thrown together
with the people who are your family but
not in the way that like somebody who is
just hanging out at a truck stop because
there the car happened to break down and
is hanging out you know in a local motel
is right it's not contingent in that
sense in a certain sense who I am as a
child of parents who my children are as
children of me is contingent but it's
not contingent in the same way as this
pure contingency right that's probably
enough about that now he says going on
we can't we cannot understand the action
as if it were only imagine that doing
him a service would promote his total
happiness whereas the service being an
immediate and actual deed produces only
a particular effect on him right we're
trying to aim at the whole person and
again it brings up another thing nor
must we imagine that service in the form
of education in a series of efforts
really has the person in his entirety
for object and produces him as a work
raising children is a very important
part as iam you know bringing people up
is a very important part of the family
right and and thank goodness for all
those people who do in fact do a decent
job in raising their children because
the rest of us are stuck with their kids
on the bus in our classes
all over the place right on the internet
in comment streams but that's not
fundamentally what the family is about
either according to Hegel this is a very
radical view that he is taking here so
again he says apart from the purpose
which is negatively connected with the
family the actual deed has only a
limited content and then he says finally
just as little should we understand the
service as a help in time of need by
which in truth the individual and his
entirety is rescued such health is the
completely contingent act the occasion
of which is an ordinary reality which
can either be or not be so you know
there are going to be many occasions
where you're within a family somebody
saves your bacon could be making you a
loan could be paying your bail so you
get out of jail could be you know taking
you picking you up when when you you've
drank too much at a party it could be
all sorts of things right could be
cutting you slack when they want to to
really punish you could be inflicting
the punishment that he inflicted at the
great point right there's all sorts of
ways in which we we do help each other
out in need
that's not fundamentally the ethical
import the ethical aspect of the family
either though Hegel say so what does it
consistent well we've already said
partly what it does consistent and
approach to the whole individual
approach to all of the individuals
within the matrix of the family within
reason of course
right again a million cousins not quite
as practicable but here hale thinking
about a smaller family and he says the
deed then which embraces the entire
existence of the blood relation does not
concern the citizen for he does not
belong to the family it doesn't mean
that citizens aren't in families of
course but qua family member it's not
about being a citizen nor the individual
who is to become a citizen and will
cease to count as this particular
individual it has its object and content
this particular individual
who belongs to the family here's the
beautiful part but it's taken as a
universal being freed from his sensuous
that is individual reality now here's
where Hegel gets a little bit you know
stranger with it and we might say I
don't quite follow along with this but
let's let's see what it would he has to
say the deed no longer concerns the
living but the dead the individual who
after a long succession of separate
disconnected experiences concentrates
himself into a single completed shape
and has raised himself out of the unrest
of the accidents of life into the calm
of simple universality now within a
family within a traditional family we do
have the dead as part of the family and
they remain part of the community and
this is the way it was understood not
just in you know here he's thinking of
traditional Greece and Rome but also in
terms of many other cultures as well and
you know if you think about you know
Christianity and the notion of you know
some sort of prayer relation with the
Blessed or the saints this is part of
that as well
I would go so far as to say now of
course with the Protestant Reformation
some of that is being swept away but in
all the overly traditional forms of
Christianity that's that's an integral
component to it so the family is
including not just the individuals right
here right now but also the the past
members of the family so he says now
because it's only as a citizen that he's
actual and substantial the individual
insofar as he's not a citizen but
belongs to the family is only an unreal
impotent shadow that's from the
perspective of the state there's
something that the state literally
cannot see clearly in terms of what
ought to be going on within the family
and the state and other ways of looking
at things like the state are probably
going to when they theorized about the
family theorized in terms of these
various functions and they leave at
something
that's more fundamental at least from an
ethical perspective